[Music]
in post responsibly news all of us a
responsibility I'll say well how does
that work
responsible responsible responsibly news
piece responsible budget yeah
submitted by Joe needs to cut his hair
you how did you know no I mean like it's
long because in Movember no in November
I'm gonna grow it long and strong why
November you need to start now I'll tell
you should grow it out long you want me
to look like a kung fu master don't you
know like Pat Morita do you [ __ ] know
Chinese Internet users will no longer be
able to post online anonymously what oh
my god online internet users will no
longer be able to post anonymously
that's [ __ ] crazy so should be in
America no that should no we need a
minute well where people can say what
they truly feel isn't it easy for them
to just use a fake picture and make up a
fake person not anymore
starting in October I know they wake
they control everything you can't even
go on certain sites they block a lot of
YouTube wasn't even allowed in China
until like the past year so they allow
copyright content to go rampantly
[ __ ] stolen and pirated all over
China but they're not ok with YouTube
the internet cuz they can't control the
energy yeah yeah we're talking billions
and billions and billions of dollars in
IP violations by the way like they're ok
with that
oh yeah they're flying with it cuz
they're [ __ ] us when it comes to
people speaking their mind [ __ ] no yeah
so starting October 1st cyberspace
administration of China will be very
strict on
all my views so pretty much everyone has
to register themselves or verify their
identity some way or form before they
can even post on their favorite favorite
social media so they control all the
social media sites so then Chinese
Twitter Chinese Facebook Chinese YouTube
all that stuff yeah after this
resolution so that means you have to
when you create an account and got to
put like your social security or
something no so apparently this one site
it's called zero which is a kora like
discussion site they've already started
asking their users to identify our to
verify their identities by verifying
their phone number their cell phone
number which is linked to people they
dedicate cards already so oh there are
ready something so their driver's
license or something is linked to their
phone number yeah like everything but
what if you want to roleplay
like sometimes I like to pretend I'm a
fare online a man a ferret yeah 14
females California yeah 13 fifa I'll I
used to down aim all the time that was
like my job female CA everybody's joke
now is my joke uniquely mine did that
yeah we all did I don't go do the same
[ __ ] right oh I used to do this great
prank though that nobody did we would
wring somebody's doorbell and then
around the world it came back that's how
you know about it that was one of my
favorite things to do in element
ding-dong-ditch [ __ ] yeah
you haven't named it - yeah wait so what
are your thoughts on this whole thing
you want an immunity
it's pronounced immunity an anonymous
anonymity animated me
yeah Animaniacs yes absolutely well and
it's a different story over there cuz
for them it's like hey I remember the
following gone I would love to be
anonymous because I I rebel against this
government and I don't wanna be killed
for hep for freaking why they're doing
it exactly right through why they're
doing it there's not like to stop online
tools I just don't anything that
controls thought control any thought
control thing with suppressive don't
like I don't agree with and that's why
I'm against all this [ __ ] in America
where it's like online trolls should
have to register so we know who they are
as they post
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah totally
no yeah that's a thing that's something
happy more but you have like five other
accounts that you go on and troll with
you're like first sure but also I think
eventually it always leads down that
road to where your China and you're
limiting people's thoughts and [ __ ] I
have a problem with it because I'm one
of the guys on the bottom if I was the
ruler on top I would love it
the O'Malley is scared place I said
Queen and I'm [ __ ] scared of [ __ ] I
know that's my really good something
about team her kids the caregiver and
holder of babies so basically just a
Mexican lady in Jabalia the holder of
babies what can we build new baby master
of nannies yeah but uh yeah I mean while
they're saying in this article how if
you look on their version of Twitter or
Weibo meatball but yeah apparently if
you look on that site and you try to
look at what people are saying about
this whole move you can only find
praising one so people say of course
oh really interested have been
implemented ages ago
and then another one says freedom of
speech doesn't mean you're a responsible
person being responsible with your
speech is true freedom China is North
Korea life it used to be crazy like
stalinís when it was a mouth but then it
started to chill out because they
realized money's kind of good and then
they go you know what capitalism is kind
of good they're balling you know we
won't tell the people that because
socially we'll just control the [ __ ] out
of them like it's all communism but
we'll let them have some money it's
supposed to be a communism but it's not
it's not
oh no they trade like crazy they love
money yep why is there still like crazy
amounts of party not everyone can have
play the same game I mean the middle
class is getting stronger that's for
sure
but it's just billions of people I think
with that much population it's gonna be
hard to you know do away with poverty
yeah but apparently people enjoy that
really they love it they love it that's
unanimous
hey it's just like half the Castro has
always got elected like 99% yeah people
just absolutely you know love because
we're good at campaigning that's why
like the venezuelan guy chavez exactly
he's like oh it's chavez again you saw
them how one great campaigner stopped
trying to tear that man down you know i
really people hate me but I really look
up to dictators because like I mean how
can they do your mind girl you you get
to always be no you this is what this is
my thought process right on everyone's
just jealous because it's like man [ __ ]
you because in reality they wish they
were doing that too it's kind of like we
look at our celebrities and it's like I
can't believe you're so [ __ ] famous
you have all this money and like maybe
you do I don't think I've ever been like
I wish that was me you know one thing
like most people thank God George
Washington wasn't like you joke cuz cuz
they offered him King and he said no no
thanks really
you so I would have done it I just want
to just run blink twice deeply trouble I
don't want any whisper I don't want
people to look up to me I just want to
have cash and then live great and say
whatever you want cuz you could live
like a king just based on money alone
that's that's that's America yeah yeah I
just want to say whatever I want
yeah I love to how you know in America
we're all like you know we got yeah
Facebook and all these guys we're
basically doing all the same [ __ ]
YouTube now facial recognition
regulating speech now everywhere
Facebook regulating speech everywhere
like what's the difference between US
and China in ten years from now we don't
do something about it soon oh god I mean
that by the way people like all this all
this like speeches hate speech or like
free speech is hate speech now like all
this goes down the road to China where
it's now a crime or a thought crime to
think a certain thing or believe a
certain thing that is not considered PC
or acceptable by our culture it's good
it's because there's no objective
definition so like what one person finds
extremely inappropriate and offensive
the other person sees as like no this is
a necessity or this is this is a piece
of art this is I don't know what it used
to be like I won't
I don't agree with what you say but I
will fight to the death for your right
to say it
and now that is just [ __ ] gone dude
exactly like wow the whole world sticks
up for the offended like we can't talk
about certain things or else you know
that will affect the way the viewers see
it or like the monetization of
everything yeah what about it what about
in extreme cases where people are
intentionally cussing at you and
throwing threats and saying they want to
kill you
threats are different threats are
different yeah yeah cussing at you in
what context and threats threats in what
context is my thing yeah but but by all
means I hear on the side of free speech
and I hope we all do more so than not
yes I think it's like at some point with
the internet people lost decency right
because now they have anonymity so it's
like decency I've never had decent when
we were growing up though like you you
would make a joke to someone or you
would say something inappropriate to
them but it it that I don't remember as
a child things being so volatile so I
think now it is more volatile it is like
it heart like people like the people
that are trolling hard sometimes they
troll too hard and that really does her
people and then people commit suicide
and then but then it's like I'll tell
you what the real problem is is cuz we
put a stop to physical bullies you
should bring that shame and brother I
agree cuz remember the the say what
sticks and stones may break your bones
the words will never hurt me right it's
the opposite now now it words hurt more
to beat my ass instead right it's it's
also people don't get consequences for
being a bully because back in the day
let's say you are a big bully and you
bullied a little bit too many people and
one day a bigger bully comes around and
[ __ ] you up and you start realizing
maybe you shouldn't be a smartass or
maybe you shouldn't talk outta line or
whatever and there's just this social
pecking order and like people learned
their lesson but now with online you
could just go [ __ ] hard hard hard and
be an [ __ ] 24/7 without any
accountability but I'm fine with it I'm
totally chill with that yeah maybe it
depends on the level we're talking about
because there's harmless level is that
we have thirty five year olds and we
have twelve year olds in the same space
it shouldn't be like that because you
have like the worst depths of what a 35
year old can say harming the mind of a
12 year old kid and that's where the
problem lies is that we don't realize
who we're talking to we don't realize
that it's a child versus an adult and in
there and it creates a lot of damage
yeah I remember this one time so I made
a video when my dog died and I was like
bawling my eyes out I was [ __ ] out it
was a really vulnerable moment and then
a guy was like man I was I was a big fan
of you until you showed the world what a
[ __ ] you are yo that's kind of funny but
that's [ __ ] up dude yeah I could I
click the site and it was a it was like
a guy that loved to ride motorcycles and
he looked like he was in his 50s yeah
and I'm all like dude what the [ __ ] man
if I was like if I was like 14 that [ __ ]
wouldn't really hurt but at the same
time I was like that is not something
you expect from a 50 year old man you be
surprised though like so I have a
cooking format on my on my channel and
sometimes people that are looking for
cooking videos like older ladies will
search in my video will come up on SEO
and I have a potty mouth me like I curse
all the time and they leave the worst
hate messages like they're like you have
a dirty mouth you filthy [ __ ] clothes
on or whatever though nothing wasn't
[ __ ] but they'll be like put some
clothes on have some decency but they'll
he was so like a really [ __ ] crude
message you'll be okay because I have a
cooking salmon coming out it must be
worse I click on it and you think you
know like you think it's like a 12 year
old boy putting putting a woman down
like that but then you click on it it's
like these older ladies they're like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] clean your mouth all that
comes comes from jealousy dude I feel
like older ladies they just hate young
women for some reason hey guys thanks
for watching that last video make sure
to follow us on instagram @ JK films to
watch more videos right up there
[Music]